monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
contrairement à ce que prétendent depuis
des mois les trafiquants de fake news et
résistants des boulevards les as not
been de la chanson française et les
sakharov de la dictature sanitaires nous
avons aujourd'hui trois certitudes
premièrement le vaccin empêche l'immense
majorité des formes graves deuxièmement
la probabilité d'un séjour en
réanimation est dix fois supérieur chez
les non vaccinés troisièmement les
services d'urgence sont remplies par la
petite minorité qui refusent la
vaccination
la conclusion est d'une simplicité
biblique il faut vacciner
pour vacciner le plus de monde possible
le plus vite possible
92% des français l'ont compris par les
anti vaccins depuis un an il nous tanne
avec leur convaincre plutôt que
contraindre nous disent de faire de la
pédagogie de ne pas stigmatiser ceux qui
stigmatisent tous les autres il faudra
bientôt vacciner en cachette et raser
les murs pour ne pas les déranger
eh bien nous ne l'ont pas raser les murs
nous allons réponse est d'abord aux
politiciens aux abois qui essaient de se
refaire la cerise on philosophe de
comptoir qui confondent liberté et
irresponsabilité aux agités du télé
bocal qui crient à la démocratie bafouée
l'est filippo asselineau le pen dupont
aignan ou melançon ce pacte
germano-soviétique de la désinformation
ont été
ont été successivement pour la
chloroquine contre le vaccin contrôle
pas sanitaires et maintenant contre le
pass vaccinale avec une infaillibilité
absolue dans l'ameublement ces amoureux
des dictatures il faut quand même qu'ils
soient gonflés pour accuser le
gouvernement et le parlement de prendre
des mesures liberticides
s'il avait été au pouvoir la vaccination
aurait perdu des mois et les morts
aurait été bien plus nombreux comme chez
leurs amis ball sauna roulante ivax ou
poutine et son vaccin est inopérant
réclamant agrandi réclamé à grands cris
par mélenchon et dont même les russes ne
veulent pas les français n'auraient eu
droit
les français n'auraient eu droit qu'aux
remède bidon d'un gourou rocambolesque
validé par la twitter schools m'a
dessiné la facebook university ces
stakhanovistes de l'erreur et du cynisme
sont contre le pass vaccinale pas pour
préserver la santé de nos concitoyens
mais pour récupérer les voix des
extrémistes quoi que vous fassiez
monsieur le ministre pour eux vous ferez
mal je vous suggère une idée pour
vacciner les 5 millions qui manquent à
l'appel interdisez le vaccin ils
exigeront que tout le monde se leva
s'injecter
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ça suffit à 300 mille cas par
jour il est temps de répondre il aussi
plus que temps de faire front la
démocratie ce n'est pas s'agenouiller
devant une minorité inconsciente qui
peuplent aujourd'hui les services
d'urgence qui fait pleurer de rage et
d'épuisement les soignants voyant leur
lit rempli de patients qui n'aurait
jamais dû s'y trouver et qui en saas
tous les autres la démocratie ça ne
consiste pas à écouter des rebelles de
supermarchés sauter comme des cabris
avec leur pancarte en criant liberté
des quinze ans de ma vie comme médecin
dans les guerres ou les épidémies
j'ai tiré une leçon simple ce sont les
virus qui bafouent les libertés pas les
vaccins et si l'on ne prend pas les
mesures qui s'imposent c'est l'épidémie
seul qui en décident et toujours de la
façon la plus violente et la plus létale
il faut donc parce qu'il n'ya pas de
liberté absolue comme le disait philippe
bas tout à l'heure trouver l'équilibré
entre des libertés contradictoires et
prendre les bonnes décisions même si
elles ne plaisent pas à tous c'est ce
que vous nous proposez aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre et c'est ce que
nous allons faire avec vous oui le pass
vaccinale est une façon de poursay la
vaccination et pour tout dire l'idéal
serait la vaccination obligatoire comme
il en existe onze autres sans que
personne ne lui hurle à la tyrannie
vous ne la propose est pas
attendez la fin attendez la fin vous la
proposer pas parce que vous craignez que
les boutefeux ne finisse par déchirer un
pays exténué et parce qu en démocratie
il n'y a pas de moyen infaillible de
l'imposer et vous avez sans doute raison
alors va pour le pass vaccinale les
offusqués professionnels diront que vous
créer deux catégories de français alors
que ce sont eux qui se place en marge et
nous met en danger ils diront que
voulait stigmatiser
alors que depuis un an il traite et
vacciné de moutons les soignants de
collabo qu'ils saccagent les permanences
des élus et les menaces de mort mais
nous allons poursuivre ensemble
calmement la lutte contre l'épidémie
malgré eux et avec l'immense majorité
des français car en dépit des campagnes
incessantes sur les réseaux sociaux
antisociaux
les français ont montré une remarquable
compréhension une remarquable patience
et une remarquable responsable t malgré
les intox la france est dans le peloton
de tête des pays les plus vacciner les
réseaux ont même eu une vertu après deux
ans de bobards nos concitoyens ont fini
devant l'énormité des fake news par se
faire une solide opinion sur ceux qui
les diffusent et je préfère ne pas
répéter ici des épithètes dont il les
gratifie quant aux discussions dans les
repas de famille où se trouvait un anti
vaccins pendant les fêtes elles ont
vacciné définitivement des millions de
français contre les absurdités et se
vexer vague par sens il est d'une grande
efficacité
[Applaudissements]